good morning
who's ready to talk about feelings
i'm just kidding actually i'm not we're
totally going to talk about feelings
right now
um so as you know my name is jen and i'm
here to talk to you about emotional
safety so let's start
doing that so what is emotional safety
well i think that's a terrible question
i mean to ask that question presupposes
that in a room of maybe the smartest
most talented technologists gathered at
this very moment
that they don't understand why the way a
person feels
wouldn't be important while they're at
work
that the way a person feels doesn't have
any sort of impact on their
work could that be true
well statistics tell us a story
according to the world health
organization in 2012
so two years ago the leading causes of
death in high
to upper middle income countries so
think like here in the u.s
and in the eu the leading causes of
death were heart disease
stroke and chronic obstructive pulmonary
disease
or copd so that's things like chronic
bronchitis or emphysema
in 2012 265
000 people died from heart attacks or
heart disease
221 000 people died from strokes
and 81 000 people died from copd
contributing factors to most of these
preventable conditions
or things like high blood pressure
high cholesterol diabetes conditions in
which stress can be a major contributor
and in 2012 over half a million people
lost their lives because of it
and that might not seem like a lot of
people but think about it in this way
that's the same as nearly everyone in
the city of portland
dying within a year
just one year
how can this be you're asking yourself
right now
surely the stress that those people
experience in their jobs is not the one
that i
experience in mine they must be like
crazy oprah levels of busy and
overwhelmed and stressed out
to the complete max
that could be but i think it's far more
likely that the stresses they were
experiencing
are the same that are now considered to
be normal
work stress experiences
explain this to me jen you're saying
well okay
that's totally why i'm here so
welcome to the polyvagal theory don't
worry
it's a quick trip oh wait a second
this is going to make it more official
oh no i knew this was gonna happen
okay feeling official let's take a look
oh gross
so basically in the polyvagal system
your autonomic nervous system
or i'm going to call it the ans because
i totally love abbrev's
it's the system that's taking in all of
the stimulus that you're experiencing
right now
it controls a lot of the things that
you're doing automatically get it
autonomic automatic okay
um so it's controlling the things you're
doing automatically like breathing or
blinking without you even thinking
and this involuntary support system is a
wonderful
feature of the human body however
one of its central bosses is this vagus
nerve that's part of your brain stem
like i know it's gross um and it's
connected to all of your crucial inner
element
inner elements like your heart and
respiratory and gastrointestinal tracts
all those guys
the polyvagal theory suggests that the
vagus nerve triggers these crucial
systems
in three different ways via information
gleaned by your ans
without your control or your knowing
you've all heard of fight or flight
before right
those survival type instincts well your
ans is constantly scanning your
environment
all around you to determine what your
current mode of survival should be
there are three modes of survival
safety danger and too late basically
just kidding the last one is life all
right you guys can see that so let's
talk about safety mode
when your nervous system determines that
you are safe you are operating at your
body's
optimum mental and emotional levels your
ans goes into
rest and digest mode which basically
means that it's operating at its full
capacity so that you don't have to
consciously think
about how on all of your systems are
they just
are this is the level that you want to
be at to do your best work
all of your work
danger mode it's not really as cool as
it sounds
when you're exposed to danger
unconsciously your body goes into
hyperdrive
your heart rate increases your ans
jumps into action and it limits the rest
of your system's ability
in order to keenly focus on the danger
and to do this it floods your system
with norepinephrine
which is a fun hormone that causes
vigilant concentration
additionally in danger mode you are more
prone
to unexpected bouts of rage or panic and
this is the fight
or flight of the fight-or-flight impulse
and it's all happening subconsciously
but your body is preparing you for one
of those two
outcomes and last
life threat mode when your a
s perceives a life threat it shuts
everything down
your heart rate actually decreases your
muscles tense and ready for action
that will most likely never come does
anybody here experience
back or neck pain from being stressed at
work that's the result of tension that
never gets discharged
in life threat mode you can't hear
reason this is the freeze
mode of fight flight or freeze
and based on the information that the
ans is giving to the vagus nerve
your body is constantly but
unconsciously occupying one of those
three modes
for example my body is currently in
danger mode
although i can be hyperbolic so it feels
like
life threat mode right now i'm
like super close to shutting down
so why is any of this important
well with the knowledge of that mini
biology lesson
how is it not
which mode do you think you're operating
in right now
what about when you have an argument
with someone what mode
does that look like
which mode are you operating in when you
get critical
and really hard to hear but absolutely
necessary feedback
which mode are you operating in when
you're in a conflict
about a really hard but important
decision
recognizing what mode you've been
operating in is crucial
because spending a prolonged length of
time in danger mode or life threat mode
has serious physical and mental health
consequences
so here's a list of some of them and
looking at that you're probably thinking
well those are some normal reactions to
stress gen
there's more
well things got a little bit worse
are you identifying with any of those
when you think about work
it's not good prolonged stress can even
lead to drug or alcohol abuse
withdrawal from social situations or
most disturbingly in my opinion
the chronic suppression of your immune
system the very thing that's intact to
keep you safe
protect your body from harm your body
will start to suppress that
this is important your body craves
safety this is not about me being a
woman
or being in touch with my feelings more
than you are
this is biological and it is a fact that
we are killing ourselves
with stress if safety first is a thing
you've ever heard and
nodded along to or believed this is
important
to quote our intern heather on her first
day at and yet
happy smart people are productive smart
people
you cannot deny the existence or the
importance of your feelings
and the impact they have on your whole
being that's the person that you take to
work every day
to do so is childish and ignorant and
it doesn't even make sense who would
even do that anyway
oh that's me
but okay so i only did that for like the
first 29 years
of my life so not that long
the difference between the person that i
was for those 29 years
and the person that i've worked so hard
to become over the last two
is that i've come to truly believe that
everyone has value
and everyone deserves respect
because if i believe that i have value
and that i deserve respect i absolutely
have to believe that of the people
around me for it to be true about myself
people are the value added to everything
that you do
you just have to be able to see that
and yet we say people first
and if you're lucky enough the types of
products and projects that you're
working on
those will change but the people that
you work on those projects and products
with the clients that you work with
they might change too but they might not
regardless people don't ever just go
away
i i hate to break it to you but you're
actually surrounded by people right now
they're all around you and they're all
around you when you're at work
and at home and
people are they're kind of here to stay
and i think that emotional safety is
important
because it's creating a space for people
to be
safe to feel safe to be people
which i know that everyone here is
really cool but
we we are all we're all people here
still if you forgot
every person on your team actually
every person that you come into contact
with has
an entire universe of contributions
just waiting inside of them think about
that
how many universes are in this room
or on your team
but people will always be afraid to let
that out
to take those steps if they feel like
they don't matter
because they don't feel safe
so you're asking yourself
how can i have this emotional safety
thing now
well how can you achieve it
it it can't be achieved
so that's the end of my talk thank you
very much
i'm totally kidding
emotional safety can be something
that is respected it can be something
that's prioritized
that's pointed to that's discussed
but i have to be clear that emotional
safety is
not a destination creating a safe place
for your people to be people
it has to be a fluid thing because i
mean i'm not even going to stand up here
and try to tell you how fast things
change especially people
i do have some advice for starting to
create a safer environment if you're
interested in that
it's also worth pointing out that
emotional safety is the responsibility
of every single person
i'll get into this more in a minute but
i really want to emphasize that it's
truly a personal responsibility
but i think more importantly leaders
and i know you're here you've taken up
the mantle of leading people
like it or not creating emotional safety
is your responsibility
people right now they could be sitting
at the same table as you
they're looking to you to show them that
they can be safe with you
they just need to see it to believe it
don't keep them waiting
you will not regret it it will improve
the health of your team
tenfold i can guarantee it i have seen
it
i have lived it i know there are many of
you who didn't set out to be leaders
and hearing this just adds to the list
of things that are
already frustrating you i get
discouraged too
quite easily when i discover
the limits of my understanding about
what it means for me to lead
if you are a people first person if you
find yourself shying away from leading
because of the challenges it presents
because of so many unanswered questions
then we need you
i'm a person who cares about other
people but i need encouragement to keep
leading
if you feel like you need encouragement
to
or you feel like you have something to
offer please check this out
my team at andeth and i are going to
very soon announce a new endeavor
called leadershipy it's early and i
can't say much more than what i've
already said now but
if these feelings i'm describing
resonate with you then we really
need you so go to leadershipy.com to
check that out
and if you're not a leader or you work
alone
i think emotional safety is still worth
paying attention to because it will
improve the quality
of your relationships working or
otherwise and the quality of your life
and it's something you should expect
from your leaders
so how to do this i'll tell you guys
where i started
first and foremost figuring out a way to
understand and identify your emotions is
crucial
from what i hear it's like learning a
programming language i don't know any of
them
what i did to start educating myself was
read
i wanted to logically understand these
emotion things and figure out what that
meant for me
a book that i read that helped change my
life was called positive intelligence by
sherzad shimeen
after that i started going to counseling
and
i said a counseling stigma word
but i think the stigma of the girl that
was feeling like a crazy person every
day at work and couldn't manage her
emotions and didn't have the tools or
the ability to have a dialogue about
what was going on
i think that's a way worse stigma than
the person that passionately
goes after improving their mental health
in their situation
so i'm comfortable with that stigma
and i think one of the most important
things you can do to educate yourself
is to start practicing having
uncomfortable conversations
and i don't mean that you're having
conversations with the
intent to make someone feel
uncomfortable
but uh emotional safety is about
being able to talk to people about your
emotions and if you don't know how to do
that you need to start practicing having
those conversations
and i've done that with my team trust
was built as a result of that
so i would encourage you to look into
that
reactions when i talk about emotional
safety people usually feel like
it will make the workplace murky and
that's absolutely false
so much of learning about mental health
is understanding the
absolute necessity for boundaries
and learning to identify your personal
boundaries is key
what are boundaries well i actually
can't tell you that because everybody's
are different
but i can lead you in the direction of a
book by henry cloud called boundaries
and this dude he knows stuff
so if you take one thing away from this
talk let it be the mention of this book
because this book will definitely help
you clarify but
i'll give you a couple of my boundaries
that i've set for an example
the first one is that i don't ever talk
about anything related to a sexual
nature at work
there's just too much there that can
offend people and it's never
ever never ever never never never never
ever worth it
another hard boundary that i've had to
set for myself is that if i'm leading a
group of my teammates
i won't vent about one of them
to anybody else in that group and it can
be hard to do
i have learned this by screwing it up so
i know now
it's a valuable thing i've learned i've
set that boundary
the last thing i would suggest is
learning to move toward conflict
and not in a way that's aggressive or
that you are wanting to thrive off of
conflict
but moving toward it
with the intention to resolve the
intention to
solve the problem
and this is maybe
the hardest thing in the world to do for
me
at least because it requires putting
your personal
things aside not being triggered
by the circumstances of the conflict it
requires learning to manage your
emotions
recognizing what survival mode you're in
being able to take all of that into
account and be able to
productively and proactively work
through the problem
that the conflict presents so obviously
there needs to be a plug for non-violent
communication here
i added the n this morning it said
non-violent communication
so dr marshall rosenberg wrote this
wonderful book which essentially gives
you insight
into conflict and a framework for how to
begin to productively
engaging conflict and working through it
so
i definitely recommend checking the book
but i want to give you that framework as
well
so this is the structure
which is aimed at giving people a
template to express both their feelings
and their needs in a productive way so
i'll give you an example
when i see you take all of the credit
for that site
i feel hurt because i worked on that too
and i need to feel like my my
contribution was valued
so can we talk about this would be one
way to start having a conversation
good question i can tell you
why i care about this
that is mila and she is very
proud of her muscles
and i want her to be strong especially
in all of the ways that i am weak
i've been trying to demonstrate
principles and tools that i've been
learning
to my five-year-old so that by the time
she's 29
she doesn't have to do all the heavy
lifting that i'm doing now it will
already be ingrained in her and she'll
be like a million
light years ahead of where i am in this
moment i'll be learning from her
when she's my age but i believe just as
importantly
gaining a perspective on emotional
safety teaches you empathy
emotional researchers generally define
empathy as the ability to sense
other people's emotions coupled with the
ability to imagine
what someone else must be thinking or
feeling
so you see empathy is different from
sympathy in that you don't pity the
other person for their circumstances
but instead you take on their
circumstances put yourself in their
place
and truly try to navigate their thoughts
and feelings
empathy is hard work
it requires emotional endurance
it requires you to do the work of
gaining additional perspectives
so i'll tell you a story about empathy
it's a hard one to tell too recently
i was in a situation where a male
teammate disagreed with the decision
that i had made
and suggested that my tone regarding the
situation needed to be addressed
my tone i was pissed i was so
instantly pissed off like a lot
a lot of being pissed off
i felt that if the same argument had
been had between two men that there
would be absolutely no way that tone
would be brought into that conversation
at all
i stood about this for
two days i wanted to summon the theory
of a thousand gens
and just write this guy off as being
small-minded and sexist and
i just didn't want to deal with him but
for all of the angry things that i
wanted
i knew something had to happen i had a
hard time
seeing what begrudgingly i knew that
somewhere in the back of me
there was this tiny quiet voice from
cascadia.js
saying something about personal growth
and i'm not sure what that was it was
really hard to hear over
the anger fortunately
i had the support of others on my team
to help me through the decisions that
lay before me because
i i could take the path that led to more
conflict
and engendered arguments and indulge
those
triggers or
i could engage in problem solving
and see that action for what it was
and try to look at the problem from a
different perspective
and it was hard it didn't come to me
immediately
or it never came to me on my own i had
to ask for help
i brought another person in a neutral
third party
to mediate a face-to-face meeting with
my other teammate
and it was super uncomfortable i had a
stomachache that whole
morning
but out of that meeting
came wonderful things
we were both able to hear each other and
get the context
of where the other person was coming
from and it's worth noting that our
notorious exchange
took place over over instant message so
it's fair to say
that we were both reading way different
things than the other person
had been typing we both apologized
and with the tension nearly evaporating
i was able to commit to helping
this man this other person in the
situation
my teammate improve
so that we could achieve our shared goal
together
and not find ourselves in the situation
again
only with empathy were we both able to
look at the situation
and recognize that what was needed
wasn't damning
that other person but committing
that we can both do better
i chose the path of emotional safety not
just for me
but for both of us
i'm saying this because the person
involved is my collaborator on a project
that i am leading
which is why i feel i have a greater
responsibility for his emotional safety
and why i am holding myself to this
standard
and at this point in the story i want to
tell you that we lived happily ever
after and the project was great and we
continued to collaborate evenly and it
was awesome
but the truth is that immediately
as in a week later i turned around and
screwed it all up
another situation happened between us
that was a thing that we had spoke about
in that meeting happened and
it just it pissed me off again and this
time
absolutely zero emotional safety zen
came to me
i got so angry i just
said screw it and i indulged my triggers
and i acted
passively aggressively towards my
teammate and just
fail wailed everywhere all over the
place for a week
and all of this was directed at a guy i
had committed to teaming up with
say a week ago to do better
fortunately i have trusted teammates who
reminded me of my commitment
who kept me accountable to my standards
and forced me to have a face to face
with this teammate and it
was horrible
but you know what i did i mean i cried i
cried a lot
i knew i failed i failed him
i failed you i felt like
emotional safety is too hard and how can
i even be all about this
if i can't keep myself together over one
conflict
how am i any different from anyone else
but in that meeting i owned my failures
and i owned my fears and my hopes
i was able to admit to all of the people
in that meeting my failure
and i apologized
because i think if there's anything that
makes it makes me different it's that i
do
care and i do want to get this right
emotional safety is really hard and i'm
not here to tell you that it's not
you won't always get it right and you
definitely won't be able to do that
alone
emotional safety is a personal
responsibility that can be reinforced by
good leaders
so yes i truly believe empathy is
equality
every person can be taught that will
improve the quality of their life
significantly
it'll improve the quality of their
interactions
the quality of their conversations i
know it will improve the quality of
their conflicts
and their relationships
i'm just going to say this i haven't
said it before but it's important
feelings are important to me
no one deserves to feel like crap and we
all
have we all know how that feels
our bodies our bodies unconsciously
crave
safety everyone wants to feel good
and i believe that everyone wants to do
good
statistics tell us a story
but i think we can start a better one
thank you
you